[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro du v y paie vers
yvelinoise personnes les missions qui
vous parle des personnalités yvelinoise
et ce soir me recevant jean-philippe
couler bonjour bonjour vous êtes
l'auteur de safari mme en entreprise
vous êtes aussi ingénieur dans le
secteur de l'automobile alors safari mon
entreprise c'est un recueil de poèmes
pourquoi safari mais pas safari parce
qu'on voit sur la couverture c'est un
safari en fait ouais c'est vrai c'est
vrai mais il ya tellement de choses à
découvrir dans une entreprise et
d'ailleurs je commence le livre en vous
décrivant ce que c'est que ce safari
alors je vous lis juste ça safari mme
nom masculin expédition cynique et
rythmé organisé pour observer des
créatures dans leur milieu naturel et là
je crois que j'ai commencé à entrouvrir
la porte parce que c'est que le safari
oui parce que finalement c'est des
poèmes qui parle de la viande
entreprises alors vous vous avez fait
une expédition dans l'entreprise ouais
c'est ça c'est le sait comment garder un
regard neuf sur l'entreprise parce qu'on
peut être très vite absorbée par le
travail au quotidien et c'est une
manière de prendre du recul et
d'observer des situations et finalement
elle parle à plein de monde dans mon
entreprise mais dans celle des collègues
et il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
commencé à me dire mais tu connais un
tel nom et finalement ils se retrouvent
dans les poèmes que j'ai écrit à est
l'une des situations en entreprise c'est
forcément la réunion le nom d'un des
poèmes que vous avez écrit et je vais le
lire à ce début de poèmes 10 dans une
salle les sujets tournent en rond
démarre en retard welcome une réunion de
toutes façons rares sont ceux qui
écoutent tous devant leur pc on dirait
qu'ils s'en foutent
c'est une vision quand même assez dur
sur la réunion aux professionnels est ce
qu'elle est dure ou est ce qu'elle est
réelle
non je pense qu'on a tous sur da tous
vécu ça alors c'est marrant vous
choisissiez celui-là comme comme premier
parce que je crois qu'on a un petit
problème de réunionite dans les
entreprises et combat très vite se
rassembler et pas forcément pour en
sortir quelque chose d'ailleurs ça finit
comme ça dans ce poème là
et vous verrez d'ailleurs que c'est
comment aborder des thèmes très moderne
liés à l'entreprise et du quotidien avec
une forme qu'on attend pas sur la poésie
oui finalement et beaucoup d'ironie
ouais un peu
certains sujets sont un peu attaquées
mais c'est le principe de regarder ça
aussi avec humour pourquoi avoir choisi
le poème est pas peut-être le simple
roman où le simple explication le texte
peut-être un peu caricatural c'est vrai
mais je crois que la forme me correspond
aussi c'est pas un enrobé il faut aller
droit au but et puis il ya ce petit
challenge dans un nombre de verres
limiter un nombre de pieds limité aussi
d'arriver à assortir le le bon mot la
phrase juste et puis je pense aussi j'ai
un cursus scientifique vous avez dit je
suis ingénieur dans le secteur
automobile mais j'ai toujours aimé
écrire et petits à 7 ans mes parents ils
m'ont emmené voir la pièce cyrano de
bergerac d'edmond rostand avec jean paul
belmondo et pendant trois heures j'ai
découvert qu'on pouvait avoir du punch
du panache tout en vert donc je crois
que ça m'a marqué vous êtes un
scientifique mais plus littéraire aussi
alors oui un peu ouais c'est ça qui vous
a donné envie d'écrire peut-être cette
expérience du spectacle sur une hausse
vers le rock ça fait partie voyez
effectivement et puis comme je vous dis
pas trop enrobés et trouver le bon mot
au bon moment alors on va en prendre un
autre exemple justement du bon mot au
bon moment vous êtes assez dur avec le
client aussi le voilà éternellement plus
exigeants le tyran de notre société le
client ça c'est dur c'est vrai surtout
qu'en plus
vraiment notre quotidien c'est d'essayer
de le satisfaire mais
parfois c'est à l'excès et on se rend
compte que certains clients abusent de
cette position de force parce qu'on
essaie de tout faire pour évidemment
rencontrer ses attentes bon un dernier
l'email email le fameux email oublier
les très cher monsieur la lettre papier
disparaît au profit d' email par
milliers à serait con à des boîtes mails
et qui sont remplies et d'ailleurs on
nous demande souvent de l'idée c'est
vrai c'est vrai et je pense que ça tout
le monde s'y retrouve les emails
aujourd'hui c'est c'est presque le fléau
de notre quotidien presque notre boîte
e-mail est toujours ouverte et on doit
gérer avec ses centaines d'e-mails pas
par jour pas toujours utiles mais c'est
aussi un moyen de communiquer large à
plusieurs personnes en même temps mais
on remarque aussi que d'utiliser cet
écrit
parfois on perd le sens de la
communication et c'est très bien qu'on
se retrouve la face à face pour discuter
de ces choses là que ça passe pas que
par écrit juste un oui effectivement et
donc safari mans d'entreprise rappelle
édition ou vérone aux éditions vérone
c'est un travail sur combien d'années
parce que je suppose que ça c'est pas
écrit en un an ça non ça c'est pas écrit
en un an d'ailleurs j'ai commencé ça il
ya peu il ya un peu plus de dix ans et
ça s'est fait sur je vais vous dire deux
trois ans pas plus est
mais ensuite il faut le temps d'accepter
d'être lu j'en ai distiller un ou deux
et puis quand j'ai vu que ça prenait je
me suis dit à un jour il faudra que je
passe le pas et finalement ça s'est fait
très récemment cette année un livre
linois qui a été publié par les éditions
vérone et en lisant dans la presse son
expérience je me suis dit pourquoi pas
moi j'ai tenté et voilà on est là vous
dites c'est un travail de dix ans c'est
à dire que ces poèmes qu'on retrouve
dans ce livre ce sont des écrits que
vous avez fait sur un petit papier je
suppose - depuis dix ans fait exactement
exactement ça s'est fait comme ça et à
un moment il ya un thème commun qui en
sortait et je me suis mais ça ça fait ça
fait un tout et puis il ya cette période
où voilà il faut il faut accepter de
dire j'ai pas fait ça que pour moi et
finalement puisque 1 ou 2 plaisent
peut-être que les gens vont se retrouver
dans plus et donc allons-y tentons pas
son nom pas de d'accepter d'être lu or
vous êtes arrivé dans les yvelines en
2008 vous êtes déjà ingénieurs dans
l'automobile à ce moment là pourquoi
pourquoi vous avez décidé d'écrire sur
ce qui se passe dans votre entreprise
alors c'est pas particulièrement dans
mon entreprise j'ai fait d'autres boîtes
avant et puis je me suis aussi inspiré
du vécu de collègues dans leur propre
entreprise en dix ans là il ya quelque
chose il ya quelque chose à faire mais
aussi parce que je me suis rendu compte
que lorsqu'on n'est pas dedans les gens
ont du mal à croire à nos situations et
finalement c'était une manière de
raconter aussi
adama mal famille mes parents étaient
dans une profession libérale que le
monde de l'entreprise
il faut le vivre pour croire certaines
situations et c'est une manière
détournée de raconter de raconter ça
vous dit que c'est pas seulement votre
expérience c'est aussi celle des autres
vous avez fait une véritable enquête
finalement c'est une expédition au sein
de votre entreprise mais aussi via des
interviews peut-être que vous avez fait
avec exactement exactement vous parliez
du poème sur le client quand on est dans
un groupe automobile le client c'est la
finalité qui est va acheter le véhicule
où nos pièces automobiles mais il ya
certaines professions qui vont l'avoir
en face à face directement et et là je
me suis fortement inspiré de toutes ces
professions qui doivent gérer au
quotidien des clients plus ou moins
satisfait est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
un tome 2 où j'ai plein d'idées j'ai pas
beaucoup de temps ce moment mais j'ai
plein d'idées effectivement j'aimerais
bien arriver sur sur un tome 2 est ce
que fins et des poèmes que vous avez
encore en stock que vous avez pas encore
mis là dedans et que vous avez dans
peut-être malheureusement pour l'instant
j'ai les thèmes mais j'ai pas le temps
de les mettre en rythme
un jour peut-être alors on voit il ya
quand même le style poétique on voit que
vous y connaissez c'est pas c'est pas du
poème d'amateurs c'est vraiment vous
respectez les règles de la poésie il ya
quelques uns effectivement où l'on
retrouve des structures classiques mais
je m'amuse justement à détourner le
sonnet avec 2 4 1 de trc les rimes
croisées mais là où on ne nous attend
pas c'est à dire ça n'a rien à voir avec
le poème qu'on a tous appris en primaire
et justement c'était de mettre cette
touche piquante qui contraste avec la
structure classique ça prend c'est
comment vous faites concrètement pour
que le téléspectateur c'est une idée
c'est vous avez des poèmes que vous avez
écrit et puis voulait retravailler c'est
chez vous ça se travaille forcément
parce que pour arriver au nombre de
pieds nécessaire ça sort pas
naturellement comme ça donc d'abord j'ai
un thème et puis je vais me faire une
liste de mots associés à ce thème en me
disant ça il faut que je les place et
ensuite il faut que j'arrive à raconter
une histoire et raconter une histoire en
quelques verres s'est passé pas évident
donc oui ça se travaille revenons sur
l'origine disons pourquoi vous vous êtes
lancé dans l'ingénierie automobile
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à nous
engager dans cette voie là
l'ingénieriste alors surtout
l'automobile c'est d'abord souvent un
métier passion voilà tout petit on aime
les voitures et un jour on se dit c'est
moi qui le ferait et puis il ya le côté
challenge en de ce secteur là il n'y a
pas un jour qui se ressemblent et ça
quand même c'est l'opportunité donc
d'avoir toujours quelque chose de
nouveau de travailler en équipe et puis
de suivre une évolution de d'un secteur
qui est toujours en pleine mutation et
particulièrement surtout en ce moment
avec tout ce qui est véhiculé électrique
véhicule autonome sur les systèmes
hybrides exactement c'est on vit une
mutation de l'automobile en ce moment
qui est ultra intéressante et je vais
avoir la chance dans quelques années de
dire je n'étais pas que spectateur mais
j'ai été aussi acteurs de ce changement
et ça c'est hyper motivant parfois un
peu de challenge ans
parfois ça crée aussi un peu de tension
dans ses mutations mais ça me donne des
sources d'inspiration alors mutation de
l'automobile mutation aussi du travail
on l'a vu ces derniers ces deux
dernières années avec la crise sanitaire
et une transformation du monde du
travail suppose que c'est aussi
inspirants pour le tome 2 way exactement
et et je me suis surpris à trouver que
certains poèmes qui a été écrit il ya
plusieurs années
résonnent encore plus maintenant vous
parliez de modification de contexte
c'est vrai qu'avec le coc vide la montée
du télétravail la limite entre personnel
professionnel elle devient un peu plus
flou et d'ailleurs on le retrouve dans
le livre avec des thèmes vraiment sur
des situations très professionnel et
puis tout à coup mélanger un peu avec un
peu de personnel mais c'est notre vie
aujourd'hui personnellement vous comment
vous l'avez vécu cette crise sanitaire
justement et par rapport au côté
professionnel au volet professionnel
alors
ça m'a pas mal changé parce que
je vous avoue que
en tant que manager à une époque j'étais
très tournés sur le présentiel et le
fait de pouvoir communiquer directement
mais on s'adapte à tous d'ailleurs c'est
un peu le but de notre job d'ingénieur
et donc ça a été un vrai bouleversement
quand même pendant plusieurs mois
d'apprendre à travailler à distance et
finalement c'est tout à fait faisable de
recréer du lien
malgré malgré la distance ça nécessite
un peu d'adaptation et du coup ça va
nécessiter peut-être de la réflexion
pour le tome 2 hors gel et peut-être
vous servir dans ce que vous avez vécu à
travers de ce que vous venez de décrire
peut-être ce manque de liens entre
collègues avec le télétravail est
ensuite le retour au travail qui a
permis de recréer du lien et finalement
ça s'est pas perdue exactement c'est une
question de volonté aussi ne pas
toujours attendre que ça change autour
de nous et qu'est-ce qu'on peut changer
facilement à notre niveau c'est tenait
qu'à nous de le faire et on s'en sort eh
bien merci un genre philippe couler
merci merci d'être venu sur notre
plateau pour safari mme en entreprise
aux éditions vérone et merci d'avoir
suivi ce direct et à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]